[Music]
gravity they were me no mercy a Cardian
for we're never to some other I don't
know I don't like a Liana or even now or
even nuns other wonders kinda in the
beta me nourishment I know my stomach I
read one other before I wrote another
idea
[Music]
veena is the oldest known woman factor
same color epa an ancient south indian
martial art the art of glory is
practiced with the use of one's bare
hands sticks and heavy swords and
shields
okay Nonnie on the granilith intently on
my favorite learn another body another
i'm mom my mother can we get another
that she's like a mother probably won't
happen if I did I couldn't muddy a nest
egg on a southern that's looking on them
okay under the desert underwater one but
you've another saying what I am raised
memory please right now run about it you
know working alone day remember that is
just I am Leah chase chef and co-owner
Dooky Chase's restaurant I'm 94 years
old I've been in this kitchen 71 years
every day I come at this kitchen 7:30 in
the morning I hit this floor and I don't
leave until we close but guests come to
this city they know where they come here
they get to get a good bowl of Creole
gumbo they're gonna get some jambalaya I
think it get some good fried chicken
they get again 12
the button just melted and get it all
kinds of good flavor every day I meet
new people and they come to taste the
food I cook that makes you feel good
this place back in the day was the label
we came a meeting place in the civil
rights movement and so you had always
Thurgood Marshall Ernest right all those
big NAACP people black people knew they
could come to Dooky Chase's and would
not be disturbed by anybody it was
illegal whites and blacks to be together
but they came here this was a safe haven
for all of us
I fed mr. Obama he was gonna eat the
gumbo and he gets the hot sauce man oh
my god I said mr. Obama you don't put
hot dog bun gumbo now that gets around
all the neighborhood so they said you
told him good mr. key don't be messing
up your cup that was recognized by James
Dean with the Lifetime Achievement Award
to be that was unbelievable sometimes I
said I don't know how I got here but it
gives you energy to keep going and my
whole thing is to make this restaurant
go I want
one of the best restaurants areas see
page
c page play play page play what the hell
is page playing this is an orchestra
comprised entirely of fleets this works
because flutes can cover the entire
range of an orchestra on their own from
the piccolo at the top all the way to
the double Concha bees flew down at the
bottom very cool and there's Paige
playing you know back from the intro I'm
Paige long and I'm a professional
flutist wait flutist or flautist
I like flutist she's one of a handful of
people playing the three largest flutes
in the flute family the contrabass flute
the sub contrabass flute and the double
Concha bass flute let's learn about big
flutes in its case the double contrabass
flu weighs approximately 30 pounds it
stands over eight feet tall and it's 22
feet of tubing the sub contrabass flute
in G has 11 feet of tubing and the
contrabass in C has 9 feet up to be
so how does one play an instrument with
22 feet of tubing for these lower flutes
it's a whole different technique your
embouchure is looser new word embouchure
um sure
embouchure embouchure is the way you
shape your mouth to make a sound on the
flute your mouth is looser bigger takes
a lot more air and a lot more support I
feel like I've run a 10k when I'm done
with a concert cuz it's hard to get a
clean low sound they actually play the
lowest possible notes of an orchestral
instrument say Louis of any orchestral
instrument now what does that mean hey
guys can you help us out here well
alright ready boys the double contrabass
flucos low lower than any instrument can
go lower than the stream bass a big old
guy he makes that bass on fly and what's
next it's the sub contrabass flute get
it
another big flute sounds like a bassoon
the sub contrabass can carry a tune the
contrabass flute is the smallest fellow
it sounds just like a cello wow thanks
now I understand so Paige what do you
like about these giant flutes in the
land of flutes they're like the
subculture of the flute community we
provide a role that the concert flute
cannot
it all checks out Paige play us out
[Music]
please put your hands together for
Danielle Perez yes keep it over those
strong gentlemen keep it going for them
listen me on stage I'm gonna hit them up
for a foot massage later when I'm on
stage and I'm performing
I feel really powerful what I'm saying
is being like Telegraph to all these
people that are there to hear my story
and be exposed to you know a Latina
who's disabled and in a wheelchair it's
just a really important thing to be
onstage representing that my name is
snail Perez and I'm a stand-up comedian
performing stand-up comedy while using a
wheelchair is a bit of a challenge first
of all people are always a little
they're just thrown off they don't
really get what's going on I'm really
excited to be here tonight just debuting
my new look which is aggressively fat
yet still very judgy
I started comedy three years ago I
realized I love doing comedy after my
first open mic people laughed at me and
that felt so good like I wanted to hold
on to that feeling forever and I was
like I need to do more of this I'm a big
girl but I can tell that I've gained a
little bit of weight because people keep
asking me if I have diabetes which is
really rude because I was hit by a train
I've gone through a lot of dark things
eating disorders depression
I lost my feet when I was 20 I
definitely use comedy to speak about
those things but also to entertain
through that find healing and myself I
[Music]
think that comedy is really helpful tool
in healing and bringing people together
when you see someone on stage that is
sharing a story or telling a joke and
you're like oh I got that I do that too
it unifies and brings people together
and it's a form of catharsis I go sit on
my therapist about two years ago but
realized I should get back into it when
I started daydreaming about walking into
traffic and I don't have feet I think
the message that I want to put out in
the world is that it's okay to be
yourself it's okay to be weird and
different you're only given one
opportunity in this world so make it the
best you can
[Music]
it's amazing what you can do when you're
just authentic it's amazing what you can
do when you just true to yourself I am a
woman with a beard when a beard is
supposed to be a manly thing my name's
had normcore I'm 26 years old I work as
an anti-bullying activist and I model to
polycystic ovary syndrome is as simple
as saying that I have more testosterone
in my body than the female sex hormone
and the side effect of the condition is
weight gain or weight loss diabetes
alopecia obviously facial hair in school
I was bullied horrendously because of
the way that my body was I thought that
the building would stop if I removed my
facial hair so I started tweezing
bleaching waxing shaving using hair
removal creams but the hair growth just
came back even longer darker thicker I
was at the age of 16 and I hit my lowest
I was very suicidal and I was just sick
and tired of all the body shaming and
bullying and people not letting me live
my life there why I want to I thought
right you're gonna grow your beard out
and see how you like her and see how she
forms in your face
[Music]
I obviously look after my bed I've given
her name as old sunder Lee I think a lot
of men just look at me because my beard
says sometimes a lot better than theirs
sorry all the negativities I went
through I turned into something positive
and I made a career out of it you know
I'm in the media actually everywhere
very fortunate to you know to be able to
reach such vast amount of people because
there are so many women out there even
men that suffer from body shaming but
don't speak about it one woman said I'm
not suicidal because of you so that to
me just really ensured to me that yeah
you know what you're doing is positive
is having a positive effect on people if
there was a pill that could reverse all
this no would never take it I can't say
I love this but I don't love that no
100% love myself
you
you